some people worry that big tech
companies are seducing you into spending
more time online also they can monetize
your data is this true yes but not in a
bad way big tech companies do try to get
you to consume more of their services
just like Starbucks and the New York
Times do this is normal it's consuming
more tech bad for you
studies show that spending more time on
Facebook is associated with greater
obesity less well being and less real
time with friends but this is also true
for television and if you interact with
your friends on Facebook your sense of
well-being is actually higher and you
feel more socially connected but don't
the tech companies gather lots of data
on you that they use to their advantage
absolutely but this is also normal
President Obama made social media micro
targeting of voters famous tech
companies just need to be transparent
about their real business big tech is
doing what others have done before only
in a bigger way and big tech successors
will do it even bigger what do you think
this big tech note too much about you
let us know your comments also let us
know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI